[Applause]  troopers are on the scene of a major  crash investigation  it is a fatality crash  it occurred at approximately 8 17 p.m  [Applause]  this was a head-on crash  one of the vehicles involved belonged to  the university of the southwest  it was transporting the men's and  women's golf team  from a golf tournament here in the west  texas area  tragically there are deceased in that  vehicle  the other vehicle involved  in the crash was a ford f-150  and  there are deceased in that vehicle also  the  school bus or the van was traveling  northbound  and the pickup was traveling southbound  it's a it's a very tragic scene it's  very very tragic  [Applause]